[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting our guest is Shay Carl the
most famous family vlogger on the
internet an interesting thing about Shay
is that he has lived quite a life before
he ever became a youtuber and we get
into that on this week's episode
including his career as a bus driver
also the time when his parents kicked
him out of the house get the dirt on
that and his beliefs as a Mormon plus
the life and death side of being a
Mormon missionary it's good stuff you're
gonna want to stick around but I do want
to tell you that I made a seriously
boneheaded mistake this week that I'm
still reeling from and I am all ears you
know I I think it's good for you to
confess any stupidity that you may have
and you know this is a forum for you to
be real for you to be honest and if the
real you was if the real you is
boneheaded then that's what that's what
we need to get well shouldn't be
embarrassed by that as my wife told me
after I did this she said where everyone
is stupid everyone makes mistakes right
because I was really hard on myself what
she just wanted you to feel better okay
here's what I did I have become friends
with Jay you know Jay you've gotten to
know Jay a little bit and Jay has season
tickets to the Lakers and the Clippers
he's a Lakers fan but he has season
tickets to the Clippers now is that why
he became friends with him that's one of
the many reasons no no I became friends
with him because he's a nice guy and I
like him we have a lot of common
interests and but the fact that he has
season tickets to both NBA teams here
Jonas doesn't hurt and so we went to he
gave us tickets to a Lakers game Locke
and I went and then I went with him to a
Clippers game and then he said hey you
know there's a Saturday game I can't
make it to the Saturday game but this is
a Clippers game which he has even better
seats with the Clippers game think it's
a Lakers game he says you know I'll give
you both of the tickets for 80 bucks
so not a gift because his Clippers
tickets are really an investment he buys
the tickets and
goes to a couple of games but he's not
really a fan so he sells him okay that's
fair for him to sell and so it was like
yeah sure you know and I was like yeah
this would be fun father-son thing to do
it's the first thing I do is when he
tells me earlier in the week I say okay
well let me check and see when the game
is during the day and I just search you
know the date and then Clippers versus
whoever they were playing and the the
game time comes up on the internet on
Google it just says like the game time
comes up and it says 3:30 p.m. Saturday
I'm like okay alright I'm gonna go to
this game and I called USA I'm like hey
I got plans for Saturday lock and I are
gonna go to a Clippers game together
she's this great you know father-son
bonding that's great so Saturday rolls
around lock has a dive meet in the
morning and then we had to do a couple
of other things and I'm like okay I'm
trying to like budget my time lock wants
to go to game stop first
and so I'm like okay I'm gonna be the
perfect dad today I'm gonna take in the
game stop we're gonna get a game get
back some of his old games and then
we're gonna time it so that we get to
the Staples Center and then we get
something to eat we sit down watch the
game but I check in on ESPN on a
football game and they put the scores up
there two other games that are going on
in different sports and I look and I see
hmm there's an update to the Clippers
game score well that must be the game
before the game because you weren't
there and then sometimes the Clippers
play a game before they play the game
and I had played I had planned to leave
it like 2:00 to 2:30 to get to the 3:30
game and it's like 1:30 or 1 o'clock and
it's like in the second quarter
my oh my goodness the game has already
happened and then I look at the tickets
that I had not looked at I'd only looked
at the Internet of course the tickets
say 12:30 p.m. game time because when I
googled it I got Eastern Time now I've
ski east and I was devastated I really
beat myself but I didn't actually hit
myself but I was very shy and lot was
upset not too upset but it's not too
late to hit yourself I was mostly upset
at myself but then the question came I
was like you know I know Jay is going to
text me later because any time we go to
a game or he said he
you why don't you just go late I mean
you could have still seen the last clue
no you go all the way down for there
he's getting potentially pay for parking
get into the thing just to potentially
see the fourth quarter I don't any think
I could have made it at that point you
would have felt even worse showing up
and it was totally yeah yeah yeah so so
I say well what am I gonna do when he
texts me because I know he's gonna text
me and sure enough that night he texts
me he says hey heard it was a great game
today so glad you were able to go and so
then I'm like what do I do now because
well you're like I didn't go because I'm
a bonehead no but here's the thing is
that I knew that he was if I told him
that I didn't go to the game and I
hadn't paid him for the ticket [ __ ] he's
such a nice guy you'd be like listen you
don't have to pay me you didn't up going
I'm not gonna let that happen I'm like
I'm gonna wait until I see him and I pay
him and then that's when I'm gonna tell
him so but I got I got a texting back so
I texted back and I'm just like thanks
again man oh you you basically lied well
I didn't say like yeah it was a great
game I heard I was just like thanks
again man nothing else and and and I'm
like okay so when I see him I'll tell
him that I didn't go it wasn't dishonest
it was just I don't want to break the
guy's spirit you know he did something
he he sold these tickets to me I mean I
don't think he made some money and
everything but this has nothing to do
with you looking like an idiot in front
of your friend you're going to tell I'm
going yeah I'm gonna tell him he may
have some way to look and see whether or
not the tickets have been redeemed
because they're his season tickets and
it's done electronically
he could have been testing me because I
haven't talked to him yet he could have
just been testing me he could be like
I'm gonna yeah he didn't even go to the
game I'm gonna text him and say so glad
you got to go like he's texting in a
sarcastic fashion hoping I'm gonna be
like uh you know I didn't go well if
that's the case then you've blown it no
more tickets for you pain or no man oh
no I'm gonna be like you gotta let me go
next time to you man and this time I'll
go you're like hey go up and this is not
the first time you've you've you've done
this even on your honeymoon way back in
the day you ended up going to the
airport a day late you were like you
missed it by a whole day
didn't go the airport I was on the phone
with the airline as my plane was flying
off I was in my bathing suit at the
resort and the plane was leaving the
ground so I missed it by a day and we
had a Christmas party one time you
showed up a week early that's not true
but no no my wife and I went to a
Christmas party back in North Carolina a
couple years ago it is she showed up a
woman early one hour late but one week
early so we were we got there at like 7
p.m. when we supposed to get there at 6
we've made this dinner we got all that
and then we go to the person's house
they're like what you guys doing here
we're like we're here for the Christmas
party
sorry we're late that's next week we my
family we make scheduling errors and
usually me I make scheduling errors and
I am I have such a fear of making
scheduling errors that I never do it
like I'll be showing up at somebody's
door and I'm okay
before I knock on the door is this the
right day like because I feel like I'm
very prone to it and I'm over correct so
yeah I guess I'm just not as boneheaded
as you in this this particular area you
know the funny thing is if you would
have blogged and videotaped this whole
thing you could put it on a channel with
like you and your son and it could be a
whole family vlog thing just like
shaycarl yeah you could you know you but
I'm not gonna compete with um a few
hundred thousand views I mean this guy
has over 700 million views on these
daily family vlogs that he's been doing
for almost five years over a 1.7 million
people subscribed to it he's also got
another channel a lot another little
channel called shaycarl with over a
million subs doing well
so let's get the complete backstory on
the person of shaycarl
now
[Music]
thanks thanks for coming in man just had
a baby
my dad number five by that point you're
just like okay the next day you're just
back to normal
well no that's the thing I thought it
would be like that and we're like what's
another one you know let's have another
baby and then all sudden there's another
baby there and you forget how much work
they are and then you have four other
kids that have gymnastics and swimming
and parent-teacher conference and it's
like we have to drag this helpless bag
of bones around what else everybody
ragging I don't think I know I've
learned that after kid five now how does
the job of being a dad compared to being
a DJ coz that's what you used to do best
today when we first knew of you you were
a radio DJ didn't you look like a DJ
right now I mean with these headphones
there's amazing microphone
I loved it man it was I I remember the
days when I was a DJ and a youtuber and
people had asked me what I did for a
living and I was kind of embarrassed to
say that I did YouTube so I'd say I'm a
radio DJ and because just because it was
easier to explain and like there's
something cool about being a radio DJ
it's like oh you're a radio DJ that's
awesome and you would livestream oh yeah
from I would do a blog TV show as I was
doing my night show on z103 and Idaho
yeah there's like 2007 as yeah as I was
I would record a YouTube video
announcing that I was gonna do a live
show as I did my live radio show so it's
a little bit lower like a little bit
lower so yeah yeah the Boise 103 I chose
number one hit music channel coming up
next got some Justin Bieber Justin
Timberlake in the next hour I don't know
I guess you do I think I talked lower
when I was fat too I think it like was
choking my guilt my vocal cord much is
that more vibrate yeah there was like I
don't know but yeah people have said my
voice has changed since I've lost weight
no no hmm you said the number one
station in Idaho is that really saying
much every radio station says that you
got hit you got any you know any city in
the country like k-96 Kansas is number
one hit music Chad okay now every radio
station says that were you trained to
have a DJ voice or no no in fact they my
program director told me not to he's
like just talk normal but one thing my
probe
one thing my program director did teach
me is that your voice is like a muscle
that you can like it can get stronger
the more you use it and stuff so he you
know he there was never like you would
think like as you go in to be a DJ
they're gonna teach you how to sound
like a radio DJ but he just says no just
talk you know like you normally do and
then I think it just kind of comes
because you're always speaking quickly
and you're always like announcing things
so it's like you feel like you have to
have this authoritative voice I guess
but I think the best DJs are just DJs
that you know that just sound like
you're talking to them you know right
but if they're not good the general
manager does come in he's like you need
to talk a little bit lower or something
maybe just a pretty good detail into it
welcome to Kate 999 foxy 99 that's the
station that I always wanted to be a DJ
for yeah foxy 9999 and you're number one
station
I actually just sounded like an old
crotchety man North Carolina Raleigh
Raleigh's number one hit choice for
country music we got Clint Black Travis
Tritt you guys are country boys I
sounded like that yeah exactly
oh just like that pretty much oh man she
well speaking of Idaho isn't that where
you were born yeah no I was born in Utah
Logan Utah oh really all the way back to
Utah yeah I mean I mean where I was born
is only like an hour from Pocatello
Idaho which is southeastern Idaho like
we're like right across the border but
yeah my mom's families from tremor ttan
tree Mountain Utah my dad's my grandpa
lived in Provo so yeah majority of them
are in the Utah area and we moved to
Idaho - when my dad graduated from DeVry
Institute of higher learning and got a
job at a semiconductor plant in Idaho
DeVry is like that's like the farmland
universe where you go and you have two
kids and you're poor and you're living
in Phoenix Arizona and that's when my
dad finished college was when you know
me and my brother were born and it was
like he was working two jobs and going
to school I remember like going to bed
like kissing dad good night and he had
these little like electronic boards
because he got this electronic
engineering degree or whatever and like
going to bed
he would be like doing his homework like
building these little electronic
whatever they are and then he would come
and get us in the morning when he like
delivered ice so I just it's like you
know those early days when they're just
like working their fingers to the bone
trying to go to college and delivering
ice yeah he was delivering ice and then
he worked at Sears at like the call
center cuz I remember we'd go pick up my
dad outside of the Sears and we would
wait for him to get off because I think
my parents only had one car and so there
was this like little bar this is like a
weird memory but there's this little bar
that like stop the door from like
opening and like hitting the wall and me
and my brother would just play on that
bar for like thirty minutes while we
waited my it for my dad to come out of
work and then would like go home and
then he would do his homework
and then he'd get up the next morning
and go deliver ice again and then I I
have very like vivid memories being six
years old and like my parents would
think it was hilarious they would wake
us up and we'd be like in our little
whitey tidy underwear and he would put
us in the back of the ice-truck and shut
the door and we'd like they would laugh
this would not be a form of punishment
but yeah I mean my it was just like you
know weird things it was fun when we
were growing up because it was like me
and my brother against my mom and dad
and like we would always like you know
do things too like we was more of like a
friends relationship than a parent kids
relationship sometimes we'd like getting
these crazy fights and I remember one
time my mom and dad were like 16 and 17
yeah they got married when they were
nine I remember one time that I want
this is where I don't think I wasn't we
talking about this one time they tied me
and my brother up together and left us
out on the front porch while it was
raining and it was like a fun thing it
wasn't like we're being abused it was
like oh you think you're funny cuz like
me and my brother would always do things
to antagonize them well and so they
thought okay
we're gonna teach you and they tied us
up together and like put us out in the
rain on the front step and we were
laughing the whole time but it was like
no now we're like fighting against him
but we were tied up I think like the
neighbors probably thought they were
crazy or then after a while you had to
be like okay yeah I mean after a while
it's like I think we got untied you know
like we untied ourselves not funny
anymore yeah
let me have the ice-truck let me back in
the house you know five minutes into
this podcast and child services are
investigating my mom and dad didn't
torture twice as a child check and check
is funny I mean what if YouTube was then
it's like they'd have a great daily vlog
yeah it's like wow you know it's all
about timing right but it seems like you
might be channeling some of that some of
that now
yeah area was this I mean I just say
Phoenix actually when my dad was going
to DeVry we lived in Phoenix Arizona
so I from when I was like kindergarten
to third grade grew up in Phoenix
Arizona and so we lived in a pretty big
city where while he was going to DeVry
and work delivering ice and work at
Sears and then my mom do my mom she
worked at American Express for a while
and then I think she was like a
stay-at-home mom but she were I think
they both had jobs cuz I know me and my
brother used to go to this daycare place
called Mary moppets in Phoenix Arizona
and there was a lady there in a Miss
corner and she was mean and she was
notorious for putting kids in the corner
and I always thought it was like is that
really her name was that like a nickname
that like the kids from like you know in
the past of giving up mrs. corner and I
remember one time we had these cots like
where we would take naps and I had these
little cars and I was playing with this
little car and she was like Shay you
need to like go to sleep like take a nap
and I wouldn't I just kept playing with
these cars and she came over and grabbed
me and like started shaking me
whoa and as she was shaking me he could
like she was so mad she started drooling
oh but she was like bending over cuz I
was like laying on this cot she's like
June 8th I told you you need to go to
sleep and she like started drooling out
of her mouth like she's drooling on me
like I don't even care that she was
yelling at me but I like mrs. coroners
drooling on me now I have to point out
that a pattern is emerging you may be
the problem in your childhood is torture
and I got tied up what a nice drug to
drooled on and none of it was my fault
but her name was really miss Korn
yeah I mean I don't know where that goes
is that you know there's probably her
last name and then she's taking care of
kids she's like well I know what my like
gotta live up to it all right
so my dad graduated from DeVry and then
we
he got a job offer in Pocatello Idaho
which was close to where my mom and
dad's family was from in utas was like
oh well let's take that job because then
we'll be close to family so we moved
from Phoenix to Pocatello Idaho and my
dad got a job I think at the time was
called gold semiconductor or and then it
became a mi semi semi conductor and now
it's on semiconductor and he's worked
there for maybe 26 years
oh he's still working there yeah I mean
whatever what what's 33 - nine
quick 24 24 he's worked there oh my god
probably 25 years now so he graduated
DeVry got his degree got a job offered
Pocatello Idaho and has worked there
ever since I've had more jobs in my dad
house I'm 33 and you know it's crazy a
crazy statistic about myself
I literally have had at least a crazy
job I'm gonna give you a crazy statistic
I'm a 33 old man that's had more than
ten jobs and being a full-time youtuber
is the longest job I've ever had and
that crazy probably for you guys -
what's the second best job you've ever
had
bastard longest site's DJ Isis Drive
school bus and I loved that that was
cool I used public school yeah I drove I
drove third like in the mornings I would
go pick up like elementary school kids
kindergarten to sixth grade and then in
the afternoon I would take the junior
high kids home 7th to 9th grade and when
I would take the junior high kids home
like during the winter this is one cool
thing I did because as a kid I always
wanted to throw snowballs at the bus
I guess the bus was leaving it's like I
hit that school bus so bad it's lazy I
could tag that thing so easy from like
50 yards away up and I could throw a
football up mountain so I thought to
myself it would be cool if I let these
kids hit the bus with snowballs so one
day I got I loved and this was like
before I was a radio DJ this is how I
knew I'd love me in a radio DJ I would
always get on the microphone of the bus
and just like tell jokes and and kids at
that age they don't necessarily get
sarcasm as especially when it comes from
a like an adult figure from a bus driver
right because they would always look at
me like is he being serious right now is
this a trap yeah
right I was like you guys I have an
announcement to make all your parents
called me and said they want me to drop
you off at the swimming pool today just
like weird things and they'd be like
really like kind of excited but I'm like
now I'm just kidding you guys are going
home you have to do your homework
just like silly things like that and
they would just stare at me so you're
like everybody file out I want you to
pump the bus so as snow and there's like
a huge snow a snowstorm one day and I
said I got on the I got on the
microphone I said hey if any of you guys
want to make snowballs and hit the bus
when we want to drop you off that's cool
with me if you guys want to and there's
like three or four guys you know they
were like really
can we really I'm like yeah do it so
they got off and they're like giant kind
of test and I think they thought like I
was trying to like Batum or something
like they're gonna get in trouble
trattman
so they they tagged the bus a few times
and I honked and waved so then the next
day it was like it was on they these
kids who normally sat at the very back
of the bus they sat at the very front of
the bus today because in their minds you
could see they had worked it out where
they're gonna get off the bus first and
they built this pile of snowballs
because it takes you know a couple
minutes for all the kids to like fly off
the button Arsenal yeah so these these
three or four kids they jump off the bus
and they just start building snowballs
and I'm like oh the eyes I see what
they're gonna do and so they probably
had between the four of them like 50
snowballs like all rolled and ready to
go by the time the last kiddo got off
the bus and I started pulling away and
it was like to pay for that I'm like
peeling out and so the next time like
you guys you can't throw bus snowballs
at the bus anymore cause if they broke
the windows you would have to pay for it
well you would hate to have to throw
them under the bus yeah and tie him up
and put him in a you know no nice
container that's a euphemism for turning
the man Shea it was a torch I should
have gone right I wouldn't hate to have
to throw them on but you knew that okay
so in like lower grades growing up you
moved to Utah which is where your
family's from now when you're in that
area you're either like a mountaineer or
a Mormon or both Fran and I know you've
got at least one of those covered so
yeah how was it what was the environment
like growing up was this like super
Worman yeah super mountaineer not
necessarily Mountaineer I mean we love
the mountains like my brother he spends
months at a time in the mountains like
my dad is a big hunter I I'm not I never
like caught that fire cuz I'm just too
impatient I get bored like whenever I go
hunting with my dad or my brothers it's
just to like hang out with them cuz I
like an hour into it I'm like I want to
just shoot the gun we're just like my
brother gets mad at me he's like looks
at me he's like Shh why I'm like oh this
is so boring
we shoot something or like throw a rock
at something but I love skiing you know
so growing up we skied a lot but yeah we
live in a very Mormon area you know the
settlers the Mormon settlers came across
the plains and the 1800s and Brigham
Young said this is the place and they
settled in Salt Lake and so like you
know that's like the epicenter of
Mormonism in Salt Lake City and then
it's just expanded out there so you know
anywhere within a 300 rate mile radius
is like 90% Mormons you know so living
in southeastern Idaho and Pocatello it
wasn't as saturated because it was a
college town I don't st. University is
there go bangles but you know so there
is definitely some you know people that
weren't Mormon and it's almost like anti
Mormons because the people who grew up
in this area where everybody's Mormon
it's like oh like they're surrounded by
Mormons so it's like you know the
culture in that thick of a Mormon area
is sometimes I got to choose my words
wisely or you know it's it's sometimes
like the worst of what religious people
can be you know or it's like I grew up
kind of feeling like because I wanna I
served you know a two-year mission for
my church and I remember going to the
West Indies and being you know meeting
people that like really believed in
their faith and were really good people
and I was like whoa you can be a
different religion and be a good person
you know that was like a revelation to
me yeah kind of and I'm like that's
horrible that I thought that that it was
like wow this person really cares about
God and really is a good person who was
genuine and they're not Mormon and that
sucked that that I feel like that was
like the culture kind of that I grew up
I'm like if you're not Mormon then
you're
right in a sense you know because I
remember I dated that girl who wasn't
Mormon and we would just like any any I
was hoping we'd getting these religious
debates and I think about him now like I
was such an idiot man this was like how
old I mean that I did this girl that I
dated pretty seriously till I like left
on my mission my Mormon mission when I
was 19 years old so like you know we
almost we're gonna get married me and
this girl and was this like a scandalous
thing oh yeah I got kicked out of my
house for it yeah we're better not get
too much of that we're gonna come back
to this this girlfriend and get out of
the house and then the the mission and
everything mm-hmm so let's take a step
back and then step back through this
knowing that we're gonna feel like I'm
on Oprah Oprah of YouTube am I gonna cry
or jump on a table at any point so we're
still waiting for the first guest of
crime well Shane Dawson wrote here
thanks for letting me talk about my
problems and my dead grandma yeah as we
laughed a lot about us being tortured by
so it sounds like by virtue of geography
to being one was there you grow up in a
Mormon household your your parents
assume we're Mormons new right so it
sounds like it was very insulated for
those factors what what is a what is
life like growing up Mormon in that
sense my I would say because my parents
they're not like super strict
Mormons you know like my mom and my mom
and dad would swear you know like my
parents were the cool parents like like
my friends would like they like to come
over to my house cuz it wasn't like you
can't do this you can't say that like we
could talk about you know Derek kissing
three girls that weekend and my mom not
freak out and she'd be like Derek you
you're a womanizer you know like just
tease him about it well like some of the
whether or not I struck yeah get to the
ice-truck but you know some of the other
parents is like we wouldn't dare talk
about like girls we kissed or you know
stuff like that or you know dare swear
or something but my mom you know like
she's a cowgirl she grew up you know she
was a rodeo queen so she kind of grew up
in
for environment and her dad was he was
Mormon but he definitely wasn't like I
think he went to church like three times
in his whole life you know so it wasn't
you know like super strict Mormonism but
you know just growing up in the church
you have a lot of leaders and you know
every we went to church every week you
know and it it's weird because I think a
lot of people think of Mormonism is
really like weird like strange but to me
it's I mean obviously it's not strange
because it's my life that's what I've
lived but you know I think it taught a
lot of good values I attribute a
majority of the success I have today and
that you know the happiness I have today
because of my religious beliefs and
people like that on the Internet you
know they don't want to hear about that
when but people you know they'll say
about our family like what there's
something different about you guys you
just seem happy like what what's the
secret it's like well it's what I
believe it's it's that I believe that my
wife and I are married for eternity that
our relationship will perpetuate past
mortality that once death does not do us
part that our relationship will continue
on past these physical bodies and you
know that belief which has been a
decision like I guess we can digress
even further like since moving to LA
I've like evolved a ton as far as like
you know because when I first moved to
Venice Beach four years ago it wasn't
what church you belong to these my moved
events Beach was like oh you believe in
God you know stupid and I had to go that
was a huge culture shock for me because
you know one I grew up in this very
straw you know thick Mormon culture and
then I serve a mission in the West
Indies which is very religious you know
I was in Barbados Trinidad in Guyana and
it was there was no atheist it was
you're either Anglican Catholic Baptist
and then when I was in Trinidad in
Guyana it was easier ear there Hindu or
Muslim so everybody had a religion it
was just like what religion did you
follow and then when I moved to Venice
Beach it was like the majority of people
were not religious didn't believe in God
at all so that was weird I was like oh
what you don't even believe in God and
people are like you're cute that's cute
do you believe in Santa
Touche you know that all that kind of
stuff so I was like and then
you know just being on the internet all
that stuff has happened to so that's
where I've had to kind of like ask
myself those questions you know like
over time going on my mission being a
dull living in different in places and
living in LA for last year it's like
wait a minute do I believe in this like
I can't prove there's a god I've never
seen him I've just I have this you know
these teachings from my parents and I
have a few experiences where I feel like
it was God that made me feel these way
or or have these experiences so honestly
it's come to a choice because I don't
know I mean if if we live I don't think
anybody knows you know if we actually
live past this
you know mortality but I like the
outcome of it better if we do so it's
like I've made the decision to believe
in God and to be faithful to him and his
commandments and that how do you deal
with the I mean the perception that
Mormonism is an odd religion I mean yeah
there's the okay you're married for
eternity thing but then people talk
about yeah there's also they wear holey
underwear and they're gonna populate
their own planet that's kind of the
point you're gonna take your wife and
populate another planet right I mean
people are me Google and Mormonism after
this no I mean the doctrine uh it can be
like like when I started to like look
into it and like really research it was
like this is a pretty crazy story you
know like Joseph Smith claims that he
saw God in Jesus Christ and that they
were two separate people that looked
like us that were like you know a father
and a son that they're literally two
separate people and he said that he saw
them and that he needed to start this
new religion it's like oh well you know
how convenient you know that God and
Jesus comes to you Joseph Smith and
tells you to start this new religion but
you know with all of like the
anti-mormon literature and you know all
that kind of stuff
to me and it says in the Bible by their
fruits you shall know them and the
fruits of the gospel that I follow have
brought me more happiness than anything
I've ever you know tried you know
because I haven't been
faithful to the my church my whole life
you know I've experimented and done
other things you know that are anti or
not anti but you know counter what my
religion teaches but I have found that
by obeying the things CI my paradigm has
shifted as far as how I defined
Commandments I think before Commandments
were like don't do this and don't do
this these are fences and if you cross
these fences boy you were in trouble
like to me I think before that's what
Commandments were like don't do this
don't do this don't do this rigor to me
in trouble my parent I must shifted in
the fact that to me Commandments are
just like instead of fences they're more
of like steps that lead me to a higher
ground
that bring me to happiness that protect
me honestly because by obeying these
Commandments and doing the things I hate
to even call them Commandments because
it's just like I hate calling them oh I
hate saying obey the commandments cuz it
just sounds so imposing you know to me
these quote-unquote Commandments are
just God saying hey if you want to be
safe and healthy and happy these are the
guidelines you should follow and if you
follow those things you'll be a you'll
have you'll fill peace you'll feel you
know settlement you know like just for
instance you know Joseph Smith revealed
a word of health that Mormons are well
known for called the word of wisdom
which is and he revealed this in in the
early 1800s which at the time was no
alcohol no tobacco and you know didn't
have drugs weren't as prevalent back
then but that was crazy talk I mean he
also it ghost the word of wisdom goes as
far as say eat meat sparingly and eat
fruits and vegetables and whole grains
kind of like a vegan lifestyle which is
now in LA like very popular and known as
like a very healthy way to live in
Mormons there's been multiple studies
that show Mormons live on average ten
percent longer than normal
population because they abide by these
health code you know no caffeine
anything I'm not drinking a cola right
now
retinol II do not refill that's caffeine
caffeine oh thank you
we didn't push it on you caffeine I'm
away from the house my wife won't know
but you know so I like that it's like
you know how would Joseph Smith know in
the early 1800s
you know there's little like nuggets or
it's like okay like that sounds like a
hoax like he saw God in Jesus Christ but
then there's things that's like wait a
minute why would that would be very
unpopular if you're if you come to these
people say hey God in Christ came to me
and he wants you guys to stop drinking
alcohol because if you do research in
the early eighteen hundreds in America
everybody was an alcoholic like
everybody drink that's how you like
people got through the hard times as a
lot of people drank alcohol and for him
to come to them and say no more drinking
people were like what are you stupid or
no coffee like things like that that
were so like why can't we have coffee
that seemed like a very like in my mind
I think why would he if he made up the
religion why would he why would that be
a part of it cuz that's just more wives
right right right
uh which is see that's been another
question like what's up with the
polygamy thing in my mind and I don't
know what the the truth is I believe
that this is can really get into this I
believe God needed a sturdy people and
he needed to perpetuate that the process
of making more you know sturdy people to
live in those times and polygamy was a
way to do it you know if you know and
also polygamy it wasn't because you know
every time you hear about polygamy it's
like oh these bunch of horny dudes just
wanted have sex with a lot of women you
know to me at the time you know a lot of
these men there were a lot of there's a
lot of women without husbands you know
so it was also like kind of like a
patriarchal thing where it's like they
provided for these women and these
children and then I think you know and
this is all just you know I don't know
I'll you know the exactly wise but you
know these are questions that I've had
to ask myself but I think at the end of
the day I really like what the gospel
teaches you know as far as families as
far as you know abstaining from things
like that and I don't know it's it's
just it's brought me happiness and I
think that's at the end of the day
that's what I want I want to be happy
that's I always say to my kids make you
guys why do we go to church so we can be
happy like that's the answer I want from
them not so that God's not mad at us
like I really believe that there's a lot
of good things even if you're not
religious just have being part of a
community being part of an organization
of people who help and you know we teach
our kids for instance to pay their
tithing to pay 10% of our income we have
what's called fast offerings once a
month we go without two meals like it's
on fast and testimonies Sunday we don't
eat for two meals and the money that we
would have used to buy the food for
those two meals we give to as a fast
offering so little things like that I
think teach the kids really good
principles and you know ultimately I
think the most important thing is to
follow Jesus Christ his attributes you
know
kindness charity love patience I've just
been listening to a tape of my truck and
it talked about how Christ was friends
with you know sinners all these people
that today a religious persons like I
wouldn't be caught dead with that person
those are the kind of people that Christ
hung out with and that's I feel like is
the ultimate goal is to just try to
follow and be like him and I think
because I mentioned the holy underwear
now everyone just want but yeah well
honestly I just want to know is shame
for me yeah I wear it's a commitment
okay so there's temples you guys you see
the temples those are like so we believe
that there's a lot of there's a lot
about the temples so we believe in
baptisms for the dead where Christ said
you have to be baptized in or in order
to get into heaven so you know cuz
juanzi kalonzo or I don't know some guy
that lived in Africa who never even
heard of Christ how would that be fair
if Christ said everybody has to be
baptized in order to get to heaven how
would that be fair if this guy who had
never seen Western civilization or heard
of Jesus Christ how could he not get
into heaven so we believe that we can be
baptized for and in behalf of these
people in proxy so that's one thing that
we do in the temples as we're baptized
for them and then we make commitments
and the garments are kind of like a
reminder of the commitment that we made
to obey God you know
follow the commandments and to you know
basically give I think it's more about
loyalty you know like because we've been
given so much we believe that all that
we have is because of our Heavenly
Father so it's a it's a commitment to
him and the garments are just like a
reminder of that commitment they animate
I was like it's a private commitment
because yeah it's a very personal you
know its underwear let's see it right
now and you guys want to see it cuz I
see my later just like it they're not
weird or anything they're just let's
like an undershirt lace milk cuz I do
like a lot of different I want to show
it yeah I want to see it you can there's
like different like they can get cotton
my dad was in the army and he because
you I do want to see it I'm not gonna
show you right now okay well it sounds
like and then we get married my wife and
I got married in the temple and that's
you know there's a you know we we didn't
stand we knelt across an altar together
and we looked at each other in the eye
and we were married in the Idaho Falls
temple which I actually had a very
embarrassed to location yeah there's no
worsening moment when I when I got
married the the guy who married us he
after the the ceremony was over and we
were married he said why don't you go
ahead and reach over and give sister
Butler a kiss and growing up sister
Butler was my mom right and so my mom
and dad and all of our family are in the
room and I was an Eagle Scout so like
every Court of Honor when I got you know
like a merit badge or another gold star
or whatever it's like kay go give sister
Butler a hug like cuz II know moms are
helping the kids so we get married and
he goes why don't you reach over and
give sister Butler a kiss and that was
like that was like the moment where it's
like you may now kiss the bride kind of
moment yeah exactly so he says this and
I'm like okay so in my mind I'm like oh
it's another achievement in my life you
know I just got married so this room is
full of like 30 people like my close
friends and family so I get up from the
altar where I'm kneeling across from my
new
right and I look at my mom and start
walking over towards her and she looks
at me she was not me not me I like put
both her hands up I'm like who's sister
Butler then and she's like your wife
like all right because she's married to
me now and I'm brother Butler oh yeah
got it
okay so I meet let me kneel back down
and kiss you honey it was maybe an Eagle
Scout but you're not a rocket no I'm not
I'm not but that was an embarrassing
moment in the temple so that was you
know we all laughed it was fun no I'm
sure okay anybody who grows up in a what
you would consider a subculture of some
kind of mean we're no different you have
your your stories of it crazy things
that happen to you and in this community
and you and you obviously you go you go
on this mission but we will we should
back up though because before you go on
the mission you're you get into a
relationship with a girl who's not a
Mormon that tight at that time in your
life were you thinking okay well this is
your opportunity to get out I'm not all
that and so I need to I need to get a
what do you is there like a specific
name for a non Mormon girl like the
Amish column English version now I don't
think so not I mean it was just no no I
don't think there's like a term apostate
girlfriend my mom might have called her
that [ __ ] I don't know but we're
actually friends with them now um no it
was see growing up like uh my grandpa
like I just always member my grandpa
like going on a mission was a big deal
you know like I remember my grandpa he's
a colonel in the Air Force colonel
Eugene Haynes Butler he was at you know
a very big influence on me in my life
and he like I said he was a colonel in
the Air Force he had this giant house in
Provo Utah it was like Grandpa Butler
like he was just like this strong
stalwart man who was you know ahead
colonel in the Air Force and like you
didn't mess with him every time we
pulled it to his house he had this giant
American flag flying and I always
remember as a kid he would like say che
only 11 years tell your mission and like
all throughout my life is like only six
years tell your mission you know so it
was like kind of like in my mind was
like I'm gonna go on this mission you
know I'm gonna serve two years for my
church and so then it was like you know
I was very well behaved until like my
senior year in high school and then it
was like
I worked at this restaurant where
everybody drank and it was like
everybody partied and they I was the
Mormon guy you know so and they would
always be like come on do don't you want
to drink I'm like no no I don't drink
and they're like don't you want to say
that you've tried it at least I'm like
no I would prefer that if I could say no
I have never tried it because all of you
losers do it
and there was like it was so funny to me
out hear these stories of like oh man we
got so wasted last night I remember what
happened I'm like that doesn't sound fun
like you don't even know what you did
but then I I remember the first beer I
drink it was like my senior year and
this kid named Jake Jones finally talked
me into it it was this weird thing like
who he's always trying to get me to
drink and it was like his mission is
like come on dude just try it just try
and I'd always say no always say no
always say no and you know I started
hanging out with him like okay I'll just
come I'll come to the party but I'm not
gonna drink he wore you down yeah
serious so that's why you got a kids out
there you got to be careful who you hang
out with because it's true what do they
say that you're the most like like the
the most for people that you hang out
with you know all the time so you become
like those people so did you meet that
girlfriend at the bottom of the beer oh
I saw her from across the smoky room I
want to make some bad decisions no I
just I just knew her at school I mean
she's a great girl it wasn't like she
was a bad person or anything but you
started to at that point in your life
you started to open up say okay I'm
gonna repel a little bit I don't think
it was like I wanted to rebel and like I
was doing these things because I'm like
oh I'm gonna get back at my mom and dad
it was more like oh this is like this is
kind of fun you know this is like
interesting you know I wasn't I was a
seventeen year old guy and it was like
chicks are hot and drinking beers fun
and you know is it was more of like that
and I in my mind as I was doing these
things I always was gonna go on my
mission like I always in my mind I was
like okay I'm doing this right now I
know I shouldn't be and I don't want my
parents to know about this because I
don't want to disappoint them and I'm
still gonna go on a mission because I've
always wanted to be a missionary that
was something that I always wanted to do
it wasn't like I was being forced in
to her being brainwashed do it by my
grandpa even though some people might
say that I did I wanted to be a
missionary I remember you know in church
missionaries would come home like just
guys from the ward who I liked you know
went to Scouts with and they would go on
their mission and they would come home
and I could just tell they were totally
different people like they seemed like
mature and smart and you know if you go
out as a 19 year old into the world into
a different country for two years you
know a lot of them learn new languages
and like you are on your own as a 19
year old was like I want that like that
seems like a freaking awesome experience
and like a an adventure you know like so
I always was gonna do that but it was
just like I'm just I just wanna you know
do these things just to like experiment
with him now but like I'm gonna go on a
mission and that's when like I we go
okay so me and this girl one time were
kissing very dramatically and her
parents came home and kind of like
walked in on us were you in their bed no
ooh
we're on the couch downstairs and her
mom walked in and it was like it was you
know was I mean Warren having sex or
anything but it was like it was getting
to an intimate moment and her mom walked
in and it was like oh crap like you know
like yeah your girlfriend's mom just
walks in and it was like and she's like
yeah I don't know how much of these
details I want to give anyways I her dad
came downstairs you want me to answer
that yeah go ahead just all of them what
I needed this podcast so I don't want to
like say too much well you don't want to
say anything that Jesus is the second
most popular podcast on iTunes why
wouldn't she listen is that mean at that
point you want to jump through a window
oh yeah cuz her dad came down and
grabbed me by the shirt and like ripped
my shirt and like I thought he was gonna
beat me up it was like dramatic yeah
happen my girlfriend's mom like yelling
at their dad to like stop cuz it was
like they had like seen the fire in his
eyes and I I didn't I don't blame him I
were to do the same thing I doubt it
beat the crap out of me yeah what we
don't have any same so I was just like
like nothing like what do I say I just
wanted to get out of there as fast as
possible you're trying to get out of the
shirt
no he like grabbed my shirt and I'm just
like it was like you know how those
moments happen or like everything's in
slow motion and then later on you're
like what just happened you know it was
like intense like there's her mom Oh put
your shirt no no he's like grabbing by
the shirt and I'm like oh so I'm there
she's like get out of here and I what I
remember going upstairs and like I had
to go to work that day and upstairs oh
yeah I ran upstairs I got my car just
peeled out of there and left and so then
I'm at work I was confused
if you're like you were in the basement
yeah in the base okay yeah yeah that's
release that's where you basement
tonight I gotta make out in the basement
yeah right
upstairs got my car drove to work
clocked in to work and I was like oh my
gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh and the first
thing I think of is her mom's gonna call
my mom and knowing my mom if she hears
it from her mom
all being way more trouble than if she
hears it from me mm-hmm so I was like I
gotta call my mom and tell her and I was
like so they so even though these girls
this girl's parents were not Mormon they
were obviously conservative I mean this
was a yeah they were a Christian and it
was funny because they were one of the
people that weren't Mormon and didn't
like Mormons I think at one point she
even like yelled abuse like you Mormon
hypocrite like yelled something like
that to me like you know like I I'm
preaching all these things like you
can't do you can't have sex before
you're married and then she catches me
like making out with her daughter in
this hot and heavy situation and so then
anyways I was when you call your mom
yeah did your mom know you were you were
dating I mean she yeah definitely okay
she knew that we were dating and and
they didn't want me to date her because
they're like you need to get ready for
mission this girl you know it's like
that's not what you need to be thinking
about right now you know this girl
wanted to get married and like it was a
very serious thing so I was like I
called my mom like hey mom I was like so
nervous you know I was like so what
happened is me and so-and-so we're
making out and their mom and her mom
walked in and and this happened and blah
blah blah and she's like okay well I'm
really glad you know it's always better
to go to your parents and like humility
and like hey I'm really sorry what
happened she she appreciated that I was
honest with her because and I just was
afraid that if her mom called her I
would be in way bigger trouble yeah just
like so-and-so's mom just called me and
I'm like
what no I don't what you're talking
about you know the first thing your mom
said was I'm glad you told me but what's
the second thing she told you we're
gonna talk when you get home
you know I was like I hope tonight's a
long shift at work you know Wow and then
so then it was like okay we're glad you
told us we don't want you dating her
anymore like you're not allowed to date
her anymore
you know you were in you were in love
yeah I mean as far as I knew as far as
the 17 year old knows that they're in
love I'm thinking about marriage yeah I
mean it was getting to the point where
it's like maybe I shouldn't just and
then it was like I wanted to go on a
mission but then I was like well maybe I
should just stay home marry her you know
almost like I don't know it's kind of
hard to you know like recall these
feelings and so anyways I was like kind
of forbidden to like date her you know
it was a meeting that night it's like
hey you're not dating her anymore that's
fine you get ready for mission blah blah
blah so like okay okay but then it was
like you know I was like in love like I
said as a seven you know so like we
would still hang out now it was
forbidden love right exactly so then we
got caught again like me dating her and
then it's like her dad rip your show it
wasn't that it was just like were you
hanging out with so-and-so it's like
yeah and it's like busted and it's like
turned into this big fight or like
they're yelling and it was like fine why
don't you just move out then and my mom
you know how like parents will say
things but I don't really mean him so
she's like you know start throwing boxes
at me in my room like as we're in this
fight like once you just move out then
here I'll get some boxes you can move
out I'm like fine I will like call her
Bluff you know so I start packing stuff
in the boxes and then I think when they
saw that I was really moving out they're
like oh well no we don't really don't
you move out I'm like I'm leavin so I
pack everything in my little car that I
had and I left and I'm like I'm out of
here so it was like I got kicked out but
I also kind of left but like at the same
time they're like we don't have to leave
like they didn't want me to leave but
I'm like no you said it I'm calling your
bluff I'm leaving I'm out of here
so I moved into my friend's house at the
time who is I don't think we're gonna
get into all this this is some some past
memories leaving out a lot of details to
come tell me you're leaving out details
Rhett I'm not taking my Brit link what I
can't anyway so yeah so I moved to my
friend's house and then there was these
books
so I sleep it on their couch basically
it was a weird situation it was like my
it was my friend's house but his parents
were gone on a mission like older
couples can go on missions too okay and
they like his dad was an orthodontist
and the head retired and all their kids
like their youngest kid was my friend
who was 18 we were just graduating so
they left to go on a mission so my other
friend's parents who were like in
between jobs moved into their house with
the agreement that they would kind of
watch this other kid until he went on
his mission there's like the six-month
interim so I didn't have anywhere to go
so I'm like hey I'll just sleep on the
couch with my two buddies that are there
and my one buddy whose parents moved in
there in this six-month interim he was
in a different state so it was just this
kid one kid's mom and she was like
hardly ever there so it was almost like
we had this little bachelor pad where I
would meet my girlfriend like she would
come over there and stuff but at this
point I was like okay I'm on my own now
like I just left I have my own job I
have my own money then it was kind of
like this moment of like well what am I
gonna do like I can do whatever I want
now like mom and dad can't tell me what
to do cuz I left you know and I have
money because I was working and I have a
car as like I could do whatever I want
and that was the first moment where it
was like I'm free like I can do whatever
I want to do and so I started thinking
about it's like what am I gonna do like
am I gonna stay here am I gonna marry
her like what am I gonna do with my life
you know it's like I've always wanted to
go on a mission but you know now this
has happened and it's like I was finally
free in a sense where it's like whoa
this whole decision is on me now you
know it wasn't like mom and dad and
grandpa were there saying you're gonna
go on a mission it was like I could do
whatever I wanted so I started you know
I was just sleeping on the couch my
buddy's house trying to decide was gonna
do and my buddy's mom had all these like
Mormon books on this bookshelf right
next to this couch so one night I'm
laying there like thinking about my life
I'm like what should i what should I do
so I just grabbed one of these books off
the shelf and I started reading it and I
was like I like this like I like the way
that it made me feel you know I wanted
to be a missionary and I wanted to do
that and I'm like I'm gonna go on a
mission and so I went in and I talked to
my bishop and you know that's like part
of the process to fill out all your
papers and everything I did all that on
my own and that felt good cuz I'm like
my mom you know because before that when
I got my Eagle Scout it was like my mom
was there the whole time like
okay you need to do this there's three
requirements to get this badge and then
you can do this and then this and she
was signing everything and filling
everything out and it's as a kid you're
like okay mom yeah that's cool let's do
it but now it's like this is all me 100%
me and it felt good because it's like
this is my choice like I can do whatever
I want
i kidded your girlfriend wasn't filling
out the forms oh no she wanted me to
stay like she don't want me to go at all
so and then I won on my mission to the
movies so you you dumped her and as part
of this process yeah I mean it wasn't it
wasn't I was like hey I can't see you
anymore you know I was like I'm gonna go
on a mission and I didn't dump her
because you know we still hung out and
we're still friends it wasn't and I
wasn't dating anybody else cuz it wasn't
like I wanted to date anybody else but I
told her I was like you know it's not
like I'm breaking up with you but I'm
gonna go on a mission you know and I go
for two years yeah yeah so you know
whatever happens I'm not gonna like make
a commitment to you because I'm gonna be
gone for two years and you know you'll
probably marry somebody or I'll pride
you know change and that's because I was
who I am now like the crazy [ __ ] like
that's been my personality my whole life
I've always been like you know outspoken
in like the class clown and I got voted
most daring in junior high and so I've
always been like this crazy like wild
kind of guy and that was like she was
like well you're gonna change like
you're gonna go on this Mormon mission
you're gonna come home and gonna be all
serious and boring and I was like no
I'll never change I'll never change you
know and but that was that was the deal
is like okay I mean we can hang out and
we can go on dates and stuff but like no
mores making out you know I'm your dad
ripped my shirt off anymore and I guess
got serious about it and I just you know
I started you know reading my scriptures
and saying my prayers and doing all
those things and and I got ready and I
went on my mission and I loved it was
you know now they assigned where you're
gonna go yeah you sent out like you fill
out all the paperwork you know you know
you sent in this big packet it's like
you fill out all this information you
send it to Salt Lake City and then they
call you what the Lord needs you and so
you have no idea where you're gonna go
so I got the mission call back and as
this comes in this big white envelope
and it's like what every 19 year-old
Mormon boy waits for his for this
mission call to come in the in the you
know the mailbox and did you have a like
I want to be in the u.s. I want to be
international I wanted to be
international I did not want to like
have to take a Greyhound bus to my
mission I wanted to go somewhere like
cuz it's an adventure yeah exactly
Thank You Linc I wanted to go on an
adventure and I always cuz like when I
talked about earlier about these
missionaries coming back and giving
their mission
you know reports they would always bear
their testimony in the language that
they learned on their mission and a
majority of more Spanish so I was like I
want to learn Spanish like that I
thought that's what it meant like I'm
gonna go somewhere in South America I'm
gonna learn Spanish and so when I got my
mission call it was to the West Indies
and I had no idea where that was that
the first thing I thought was India
like I remember my dad getting out the
Encyclopaedia and it's like we had to
look up where the West Indies was and so
the I googled Tara we had those like
little blue encyclopedia Britannica's
you know we had to find the W and pull
up the West and what year is this this
is 98 99 and so then I mean the irony
about that is that I wanted to speak
Spanish really bad but the West Indies
the part that I got called to was an
English speaking mission but with an
accent right there's a thick accent the
funny thing is as part of my mission was
in Guyana which is in South America it's
in between Suriname and French Guiana
and it's the only english-speaking
country in South America so here I am in
Guyana in South America where I thought
I would go to learn Spanish but I wasn't
learning Spanish did you know I no hablo
espanol so now every time I see a pair
of Mormon missionaries it's a pair so
yeah yeah they're young uns yeah you got
paired with somebody then you did not no
no no absolutely not I didn't know any I
had probably 13 different companions
over though over the two years and it's
funny so you're not just with one guy
the whole time
oh yeah you rotate there's what's called
transfers like you transfer to different
areas within the mission I I guess I was
in three different countries over the
two years I was in Barbados Trinidad and
Guyana and you get with new you know
companions and talk about you know
because they pair you with like dude you
would never be friends with back in
school you know what I mean like when
you're growing up like a majority of my
companions are never guys that I would
like have chose to hang out with growing
up and it teaches you how to like get a
with different kinds of people you know
it was like probably the best
preparation for marriage ever like
learning how to like live with somebody
who has really weird
traits you know like why do you do the
toothpaste like that like all those
things that most people experience the
first time when they get married or when
they live with somebody I had that for
two years you know I I was companions
with you know people from Antigua and
st. Kitts I had all different kinds of
companions just crazy stories I have a
million stories about but you end up is
weird weirdo story weird words um let me
think just like it was always different
living with companions that were from
the West Indies like missionaries that
weren't from the states that were you
know they would cook weird like I had a
companion who thought that if I first
thing what I would do is I'd wake up in
the morning I'd get a cold glass of
water right out of the fridge and he
would get mad at me for that he's like
you're gonna get a cold what are you
talking about
and he's like at the butler you always
call me at the butler because you go by
Elder when you're a missionary the
butler you gonna catch cold nutboy and
I'm like what cuz they thought like if
you drank cold water right when you woke
up you would catch a cold like you would
get sick yeah that's true just little
things like that or just little
arguments you know what I mean that you
would get in just because you're with
them all the day I mean your your wit
your with your companion that's one of
the rules is you can't be separated from
your companion did you ever get in a
fistfight with a companion uh no cuz
I've always just been the kind of person
that can get along with anybody but you
know there's definitely fights where
it's like you know I remember like I was
told my little brother cuz my little
brothers about to leave on a mission in
three weeks he's going to Buenos Aires
Argentina to learn Spanish sure and so
I've been like talking to him about all
this stuff you know but I remember my
second companion his name was elder
Greenwood and he came into the area and
I was the junior companion cuz there's
always a junior and a senior companion
like one who's kind of like in charge
and it was my area cuz that my senior
companion left and went home and he came
into this area and didn't know the area
didn't know the neighborhood didn't know
the people that we were working with but
he was the senior companion and so I
remember one night I was riding my bike
kind of showing him the area
I went one way he's like we're not going
that way what do you think you're doing
and we got in this like big fight I'm
like dude I'm just like showing you
around the areas like why do you think
you're in charge I'm like I don't think
I'm in charge
I've gotten this big fight I'm like do I
don't why are you freaking out and then
later on he's like hey I want to
apologize that's just how my last
companion treated me so I thought that's
how I had to treat you I'm like okay
whatever dude people are like looking
through the windows of these two like
waiting well you know I got a gun pulled
on me I got a knife pulled on me on my
mission because you're going you're
talking the door to do it yeah i mean
we're knocking on doors and people will
show up at their door with their guns
you know what happened with the gun the
gun when I wear knocking on doors and
you know it's a little later I think is
why it maybe like scared the guy and in
the West Indies you don't knock on doors
you yell inside you say inside inside if
you knock on the doors that means you're
the police and a lot of American
missionaries didn't know that because
only the police knock on doors everybody
out important part of the organ right
she should have told you that right it's
a culture they go and so yeah you yell
you like go to the gate and you yell
inside but we knocked on the door and
this guy came to the window he opens the
window and points a gun right out it's
like what do you want and a lot of
people in the West Indies they thought
we were like FBI because it's like two
white dudes in shirts and ties we look
like we're like CIA or please really
throw it off nice but I got some nice
farmer tans going on and then another
time I was walking through an area twice
I got pulled the knife on that where a
guy's like hated Mormons and he just
like came at us with a knife and I was
like we just can't put our heads down
and kept walking and he was walking
behind us for probably like a half a
mile just yelling obscenities with a
knife and my companion who was the
senior come and he's like just keep
walking just keep walking and I was like
we should run we should rise like don't
run he's like just ki it's like a bear
you know like don't run just like
pretend you can't see him and then
another time we were walking through the
area other record that's not what you do
with a bear everybody listening attacked
by a bear it depends on the type of bear
right I will say that black bear will
you shot with the gun no I never was
shot with a gun Oh or stabbed with a
knife nope
but I was held up at knife point this is
a crazy story the guy pulled out my
wallet took my wallet and took my
companion's wallet and I was like
like the first thing I thought if it's
like my driver's license is in there my
Social Security card is in there all
those things that just suck to have to
like go and get again so I yell at the
guy I said hey I said bring my wallet
back and I'll give you the money in it
my hand to the Bible this guy comes back
opens my wallet we're standing around
the circle he opens my wallet grabs all
the cash and like the cards that are in
there I'm like wait no no I need those
cards he gives me the cards back I put
in my wallet he takes the cash and
leaves and for the record for everyone
listening you should not do that right
but in my mind I'm like oh it's gonna
suck to have to get all those things I
just yelled it and like afterwards after
they left and the whole experience was
over I was like holy crap I can't
believe that just happened he came back
gives me my driver's license I mean he
was a very polite robber he he'd not you
know I'd hate to stand in the DMV line
again that's murder I wouldn't wish that
on anybody - but not your driver's
license yeah that's that's nice that's a
good compromise it goes good guy well so
two years of that moving around I mean
any other crazy stories come to mind any
other oh yeah door to door what is the
what is is that the main task is going
door to door to win people over - right
I mean well we not I mean it's not that
I guess that's kind of what it seems
like but you know we believe that you
know the name of our church is the
Church of Jesus Christ of Latter day
Saints we believe that it is actually
Jesus Christ's Church it is the restored
Church on the earth that he initially
established when he was on the earth and
he had Twelve Apostles and he created
this church and then we believe in
what's called the apostasy where because
of the murder of these Twelve Apostles
that Christ you know Peter James and
John these men because they were killed
the power or the priesthood Authority
was taken off the earth because all of
these men who Christ gave this power and
authority to they were killed and so
that was all lost so we believe in the
Dark Ages and that the power of God
wasn't on the earth and that through
Joseph Smith it was restored so we
believe that we literally this is the
kingdom of God on earth and so it's not
like you got to get your numbers up
elder it's about bringing souls to
Christ it's about bringing people
happiness
through this relationship with Jesus
Christ and about you know how he's
atoned for our sins and about you know
that's what it is it's about bringing
people to the Savior not to get the
Mormon numbers up get the Mormon
population up I I feel like the biggest
thing that religious people don't get
are people who get bad name for being
religious is that God loves all of his
children regardless whether you're
Mormon black white gay lesbian whatever
our Heavenly Father these were all of
his children and so you okay so you have
this formative experience in the two
years on your mission then you get back
and this is now you you've started to
get married what you're gonna do with us
here yeah including getting married so I
come home from a mission
I loved it like there's a saying in our
church that's like it's the best two
years of my life which isn't true but I
think it was the best two years for my
life like serving that mission
you know just taught me responsibility
and I grew up a lot but I you know I
still kept my fun personality and stuff
anyways I came home for my mission and
this is where I've like told to all
these stories a million times because
I've made a video every single day for
five years but I went to this play my
buddy Derek who kissed the two girls and
we see how you met stores how am i want
my wife story yeah
you've told you've told this particular
story Elaine you have you know it's like
yeah because people want to know they
always want to help me and Colette met
you know so it's like so you got to give
us the seedy underbelly well with
Colette there's never any seedy
underbelly she's like the most righteous
perfect person you'll ever meet my wife
is I don't think people believe that but
she is she is seriously a saint which it
bothers me sometimes actually because
she's so good but yeah I came home my
buddy's brother was in a play called
anything goes it's a it's like a musical
or whatever and she played the role of
Reno Sweeney sounds ironic for a Mormon
group to be sing yeah yeah exactly and I
saw her on stage and I was like
immediately in love like it was you know
I don't know if I believed in love at
first sight but it was like oh my gosh
like the second she came on the stage I
was in love with this girl
one because I'm really attracted to
girls who can sing and she could sing
amazingly and she was just hot so
beautiful and I kept trying to pick her
apart the entire play I'm like what's
wrong with her cuz like to me with a
second she walked I was like she's
perfect
so I'm like I think her butts big does
she have a big butt you know like no cuz
then there's like a costume change I'm
like oh it was just those pants I just
kind of made her but like baggy it was
like she have a big nose maybe she's a
big nose like no but it was a prosthetic
nose
it was just the the Pinocchio scene but
you know so then after the play you know
how after plays usually the players will
come out and then everything the
audience will go by and shake the hands
I'm out on a date right well I was cuz I
had just come home from a two-year
mission I was afraid to even talk to her
so I stood like thirty yards away and
just stared and stared at her and I was
so like nervous and anyways my friend
ended up calling her and asking her to
come out wakeboarding with us and that
was our first date and like it was like
I kept trying to talk myself out of this
girl like no this won't work for this
reason or whatever anyways so we started
dating and like after we know on the
first date I'm like there's no use in
trying to the first day was the
wakeboarding yeah we won't wakeboarding
and I brought my little brother with me
and I was so embarrassed cuz I don't
have to bring my brother but my mom's
like you need to take your brother and
she ended up thinking that was so cute
that I had brought my little brother so
it actually worked from my advantage and
we went to subway and I remember like
because I was pretty religious and you
know just came home for my mission and
we went Nate at Subway and we got our
food and we sat down I was about to eat
and she's like do you mind if we say a
prayer I was like whoa this chick wants
to say a prayer like right in the middle
of a subway and I kind of liked it but
at the same time I was like this is a
little weird but we said a prayer there
in subway on our very first date and
thanks the Lord for the food and for our
many blessings in the name of Jesus
Christ amen and from that moment as like
I'm gonna marry this girl oh I've said
this in the vlogs before but I leaned
over on the night of the play when I
when I saw her for the first time I
leaned over to my friend and said see
that girl up there at the brown hair
he's like yeah yeah I said I'm gonna
marry her hey just because you say it in
your vlogs that's really what happened
you can ask my buddy Derrick let's call
him right now it's convenient get on the
line Derrick create your own non-aryan
called Derrick
hey guys we're cutting the conversation
short right now not because it was short
but because it was so long and so good
that we actually continued talking to
Shay about a whole host of other things
beyond his backstory right and so that's
gonna come out next week as part two
basically we you know we didn't want a
short circuit hearing what you just
heard from Shay kind of learning
everything that led up to his YouTube
career but there's a whole lot more that
we ended up talking about once we
started getting into the dynamics of
being becoming a youtuber and also
bringing his family into the mix and
shifting from just having his shaycarl
channel to having this family vlog that
he's approaching five years of pretty
much releasing a video every single day
what Anatole does that take on you as a
person we asked him what kind of toll
does that take on your family what are
all the dynamics associated with that
it's a great conversation where we
really shift gears and go into the
shaycarl shaytards world of youtube so
we didn't want a short circuit or sell
any of that short so instead that is
part two in next week's episode yeah so
you got something to look forward to a
little two-parter here yeah we can
promise it's not gonna be a three parter
though this is not gonna just become
your biscuits with the shaycarl you know
I mean he's a great guy we had a great
conversation had a very long
conversation that's a two-parter but
well he's got other things to do yeah he
probably wouldn't even agree to it you
know right I don't think we're the
limiting factor I think he's kind of got
to move on with his life right yeah you
can't just pin hours and hours with us I
mean if Lionel Richie
for instance decided that he wanted to
be here every week I think we'd probably
let that happen
oh my goodness you know what maybe let's
make that a goal not to have him here
every week but let's just start with
having him here once for one episode of
ear biscuits we won't lie or Richie
owning your biscuits that's gonna let's
make that our goal you know else you'd
be on your biscuits he'll be so nervous
dude Merle Haggard should we set that
lofty of a goal to have both of them oh
my gosh I mean I'm willing to set Lionel
Richie as a goal but
it's setting Merle Haggard as a goal to
come in here I think I just think I
would die if he came here I don't want
to it's just like might I do it what he
might actually he's kind of old but I
feel like that I might die I just
couldn't even I couldn't even converse
with the man it's he's not a deity of
you know I think we all know that he's
not a D but I feel like that I would
just be bumfuzzled well there we have I
can't even talk about it now yeah I'm
noticing that but I tell you right now
we've just got Lionel Richie let's go
let's set that off either both and
either or Lionel Richie and or Merle
Haggard need to be guests on your
biscuits before this thing is shut down
we could have them both here together
yeah that would be stupid
yeah that would be if that's not that we
do have we do have that many microphones
though okay so there you have it if you
have any connections to line or Richie
or Merle Haggard those are our lifelong
dreams hmm thanks for listening to this
ear biscuit see you next week
[Music]
[Music]